please welcome to the next level how you
doing man what's up bro good to see you
man man my life is incredible right now
incredible yeah I'm trying to be
unaffordable real soon before you get
unaffordable let me tell him where
you're from okay Ranji was born and
raised in Columbia South Carolina uh you
started coming in Atlanta I did and when
you were in Atlanta you were encouraged
to try stand-up comedy for one night by
your cousin is that correct yeah was
Apollo night
uptown comedy club when it was on
Peachtree uptown on Sunday night yeah I
had one joke and it was terrible and I
got onstage and halfway through my set
all I heard was boo and then I walked
outside and this dude was like man you
terrible you ain't nobody funny little
nigga Wow and I was like that's back
when I used to curse I was like after
you didn't man he was like if you get
you killed and walked off I was like you
know what I'm gonna just go just go
about your business yeah yeah
why will you move from Atlanta to Los
Angeles is this true because I heard
this and if it is true I'm blown away by
okay I heard you won an Emmy I did you
want to end me I want an Emmy for did
you a name I was a consulting producer
for a show called United States of
America for CNN lion we want our Emmy
season to the United States we're seeing
in and a wonder a me in my first
producing gig that's unreal yeah I wrote
the funny for the show on real yes sir
no damn window damn any all these TV
movies you're done you've never won a me
know I don't know one no goddamn in I'll
let you borrow mine ain't this about a
bitch ain't this about a now one Hemi
okay no I love it man listen Ryan first
and foremost I'm a friend always been a
fan man and you know what I think your
style of comedy dude is amazing I think
you've grown as a comedian I think that
right now it's it's obvious that you're
ready for the next level absolutely this
is no-brainer man I'll try to be on the
400 out there make yourself happy hey
Dad proud when hey you better go
flippy-floppy flip it all right
I didn't mean to stand in your be I'm
sorry
hear me scuse me he's that I didn't be
in the stand in your video
[Music]